[Music]
is teleportation possible could a
baseball transform into something like a
radio wave travel through buildings
bounce around corners and change back
into a baseball
oddly enough thanks to quantum mechanics
the answer might actually be yes sort of
here's the trick the baseball itself
couldn't be sent by radio but all the
information about it could in quantum
physics atoms and electrons are
interpreted as a collection of distinct
properties for example position momentum
and intrinsic spin the values of these
properties configure the particle giving
it a quantum state identity if two
electrons have the same quantum state
they're identical in a literal sense our
baseball is defined by a collective
quantum state resulting from its many
atoms if this quantum state information
could be read in Boston and sent around
the world atoms for the same chemical
elements could have this information
imprinted on them in Bangalore and be
carefully directed to assemble becoming
the exact same baseball there's a
wrinkle though quantum states aren't so
easy to measure the uncertainty
principle in quantum physics implies the
position and momentum of a particle
can't be measured at the same time the
simplest way to measure the exact
position of an electron requires
scattering a particle of light a photon
from it and collecting the light in a
microscope but that scattering changes
the momentum of the electron in an
unpredictable way we lose all previous
information about momentum in a sense
quantum information is fragile measuring
the information changes it so how can we
transmit something we're not permitted
to fully read without destroying it the
answer can be found in the strange
phenomena of quantum entanglement
entanglement is an old mystery from the
early days of quantum physics and it's
still not entirely understood entangling
the spin of two electrons
in an influence that transcends distance
measuring the spin of the first electron
determines what spin will measure for
the second whether the two particles are
a mile or a Lightyear apart somehow
information about the first electrons
quantum state called a qubit of data
influences its partner without
transmission across the intervening
space Einstein and his colleagues called
this strange communication spooky action
at a distance while it does seem that
entanglement between two particles helps
transfer a qubit instantaneously across
the space between them there's a catch
this interaction must begin locally the
two electrons must be entangled in close
proximity before one of them is
transported to a new site by itself
quantum entanglement isn't teleportation
to complete the teleport we need a
digital message to help interpret the
qubit at the receiving end two bits of
data created by measuring the first
particle these digital bits must be
transmitted by a classical channel
that's limited by the speed of light
radio microwaves or perhaps fiber optics
when we measure a particle for this
digital message we destroy its quantum
information which means the baseball
must disappear from boston for it to
teleport to Bangalore thanks to the
uncertainty principle
teleportation transfers the information
about the baseball between the two
cities and never duplicates it so in
principle we could teleport objects even
people but at present it seems unlikely
we can measure the quantum states of the
trillion trillion or more atoms in large
objects and then recreate them elsewhere
the complexity of this task and the
energy needed is astronomical
for now we can reliably teleport single
electrons and atoms which may lead to
super secure data encryption for future
quantum computers
the philosophical implications of
quantum teleportation are subtle a
teleported object doesn't exactly
transport across space like tangible
matter nor does it exactly transmit
across space like intangible information
it seems to do a little of both quantum
physics gives us a strange new vision
for all the matter in our universe has
collections of fragile information and
quantum teleportation reveals new ways
to influence this fragility and remember
Never Say Never
in a little over a century mankind has
advanced from an uncertain new
understanding of the behavior of
electrons at the atomic scale to
reliably teleporting them across a room
what new technical mastery of such
phenomena might we have in a thousand or
even ten thousand years only time and
space will tell
you
[Music]